I think it should win a Grammy I'm here
with Evan we're gonna try some unicorn
grilled cheese from the Instagram famous
chomp eatery in Santa Monica are you
excited I'm very excited I sent a
picture in the menu it looks delightful
let's got it I'll be rollin nice to meet
you I'm Evan thank you tell us a little
bit about your restaurant
we're like a one-stop shop we have
cold-pressed juices that we make here
burgers and cheese wraps what are we
trying today we're trying the rainbow
grilled cheese in the s'mores and we'll
do the sweet potato and the regular
french fries the unicorn belt comes with
a sour dough we put or different type of
cheese we use Asiago provolone Parmesan
and fancy coloring of the cheese very
bright and I just hate to eat the food
coloring is safe it's the same thing
what you use for cakes or cupcakes you
try like different things to make sure
it tastes good because I wouldn't want
to put it out just for the fame of
Instagram I want to make sure it's good
and it doesn't lose any flavor how did
you react with all the Instagram Fame
over the girl cheese I didn't know it's
going to get like that popular but it's
really pretty how people come in and
they like do different things with it
you're gonna like it
[Music]
yeah our unicorn your own team its
rainbow its unicorn yeah Eddie are we
doing this
[Music]
wow-whee how long can this go oh this is
better web
Oh run this is Jeff this is so delicious
and so magical I don't think I've seen
cheese like this before except for on
the Ninja Turtles like a 90s cartoon
very visually pleasing you want your
other juice oh yeah
Cheers I like a strawberry lemonade
lemonade goes really well with the
cheese cuz it's like a tart cut it is
not it's not so sweet which I like I
feel like a unicorn princess Jessie's
living the dream this never gets all
this cheese fool do you have that
buttery soft taste with the kind of
sharper cheese and get a nice crunch
into the goon Center oh and usually also
grilled cheese is just like one cheese
right this is like poor cheese so she's
dynamic the cheese is blended so well
together I couldn't tell you exactly
which cheese's they are big cheese
Stephanie the big cheese that should be
the name of this video big cheese Kelsey
another tackle the big cheese
next is s'mores fries what does that
mean alright I think we're going to find
out for the Morris we make it from
scratch in-house we use egg whites cream
of tartar and then we use sugar and
water and then we find it together it
becomes like a fluffy marshmallow and
then for the color you speak juice we
make beats from stretch like cold press
and we put a little bit in there so it
has a pretty pink color
hey yes
[Music]
Wow holy fries thanks for doing a bowl
hold on stay on it I want to do it right
wait move your arm okay is this how the
instagramers do it this is the best
photo of food I've ever taken
what is this powder that's I think
graham cracker do I go for this
Wow like ruin you right I try this one
for this sounds a bit saltier oh really
bad it's better as a sandwich he's very
satisfying the marshmallow is so fluffy
and soft and creamy I've never had
marshmallow like this before in my life
but eating clouds when I first heard
small fries I was like what but now I'm
like yeah that's how it should be
potatoes and marshmallows well I've been
Lea it looks good it tastes good
that's my theory I think all of my food
should be rainy though
are you a big rainbow person heck yeah
I'm a big durian go person Evan you know
me at all mono I know you're going to
chromatic I'm a very monochromatic
person I got like a sugar high I am a
little sugar high